you
[Music]
it is my pleasure today to welcome back
Pablo Perez who is an intern in my group
in 2011 ich well ok 2013 was when we
published the papers but he was a
wonderful colleague for us and many of
us enjoyed working with him he now is a
faculty member at Stanford University in
the medical school and he actually
started a lab called the pervasive
well-being technology lab which is near
and dear to our hearts and he's gonna be
talking about precision health
engineering today so I can't wait to
hear what he's up to
so thank you well thank you so much Mary
for having me here and thanks for
attending this talk I'm very excited
yeah so I'm here to talk about precision
health engineering and um you know I
hope I can convey the message of let you
know what's the the new wave of
understanding of what health means in a
second so when a daily basis you will
see like people who are like overworked
or a tired angry overweight unmotivated
distracted and happy feeling isolated it
will be the the dark side of of you know
what mental health like there's like 1
in 4 people who have some problems with
mental health we're talking about a 2.5
trillion dollars per year problem 1.7 of
those are due to productivity and
absenteeism issues so this is a serious
thing and we really need to understand
how to attack this so when I talk about
precision health I'm gonna focus a bit
more on the mental health aspects today
it's definitely a broader concept but I
will be focusing slightly on mental
health and stress so I'm gonna be
talking giving a definition I want to
basically say that precision holds not
precision medicine and I'm gonna spray
that explain that in a second and I'm
gonna be also giving an overview of more
applied se perspective or precision
health which will be what I call mundane
stress management basically how do we
use very mundane objects like PC mouths
or or display
a car or things like messaging apps or
just any other apps that you use on a
daily basis in the office the car in the
home and how to create how to do
research across these different
environments which is what I've been
doing so far so precision health is in
one definition of precision holds the
practice of personalized health so you
want to personalize things and you want
to basically be understanding health but
what is health like let's understand
what health means if you look at the
definition of health by the world hair
organization it's not about sickness
we're like overwhelmed by the
perspective that Held's about sickness
and it's not about sickness it's precent
sickness but so far it's been like too
much emphasis on sickness and infirmity
and that's great I mean we have to
basically to support this type of
research but not enough on like how do
we keep keep your well-being your
physical mental social abilities up to
par how to monitor the baseline of this
so when I say that precision holds not
precision medicine what I basically mean
is that you know a good analogy will be
like you know if you look at humans they
basically have a sampling frequency of
one visit per year and sometimes even
less than that to try to monitor and try
to do detection and try to do you know
prediction and prognosis and most often
than that where we get slate detection
of a bunch of problems now if you look
at the jet engine you know in the
aerospace industry well it's very
different you have continuous monitoring
hundreds of sensors hundred of super
high sampling frequency and that's what
you know keeps this like you know high
you know availability industry going so
the hope is that we can transform that
and have the human being monitored
constantly and being able being able to
really have early failure detection and
prevention of individuals so that's what
precision helps more about the baseline
than any type of anomaly and I will say
sadly the med school and med schools in
general don't really know how to deal
with this problem like because they have
been studying sick people they have not
been studying healthy people right by
definition so at the end of the
we still need to know what it means to
like do this monitoring on on a daily
basis how to measure up an and for a
long-term and this is not easy because
it's not just about like putting sensors
on people's like how do we get people to
stick with those sensors how do we get
people to like basically understand the
value of like prevention and prediction
and proactive medicine so if you look at
you know that the state of the art of
sensing you know if we focus on the
sensing part first you know we have like
the the wearables that are everywhere
but there's a huge drop out rates and
this is what I'm trying to talk say
about like you know adoption right it's
it yeah we have great sensors and some
things that are happening is this is
actually the Matt's cold is implantable
but the dropout rates are still pretty
large right and many of them are not
because they learn to do something or
they are better at using where I was
because they forget to charge it right
or things like that or it just don't
like it you can also say like well how's
their sensing in other areas like mental
health well sadly the state of there
continues to be subjective monitoring
you know asking question to people more
often less often whatever about asking
question it's not a you know at the most
the best way to to collect data and it's
also very tiring for the individual and
finally you know if you say like well
you can do electrodermal activity higher
variability or like new modes of
sampling they continue to be obtrusive
because you have to learn to wear these
things and you have to basically have to
charge them and do these other types of
things so so our hope is that you know
we can move beyond just sensing with
wearables and sensing with questions and
start looking at their environment as
well and this is one of the corners of
the projection of what it could be the
future of you know precision how do we
use houses and very mundane things
around us to generate these let's call
it health center Internet of Things if
you must right yeah how often if you go
back a slide how often do you have to
charge those shirts you're not really
and often it depends on you know the
type of sensing that you do you know
many people advertise heart rate
variability
and what they do is they sense once that
the once a day or only when you're
sleeping or when you're sitting so the
reality is that if you really want to
have this continuous monitoring there's
no good battery solutions yet for this
continuous monitoring you still we
haven't solved that problem right I'm
wearing this ring for example which is
actually useful for sleep tracking and
it's not bad I have insomnia I need it
but it works only at night and it's good
it's a use case right but the rest of
the day is that doesn't really know
what's happening with me but we're
getting close but still you know
form-factor mother I do wear jewelry so
it's better than wearing some guys don't
wear other wearables except for these
one because I have a torn ligament so I
to wear something but that's a different
that's a sickness that's not a help
thing so anyway that the end of the day
yet is a good question battery's not
there yet so can we move not only from
sensing can we also use the the
infrastructure to do they even
behavioral not just how do we maximize
adoption and adherence can we get to the
point that we can really like push that
and and I hope is that you know we can
understand why is this important you
know if you look if we if we look at
this graph that you know I've created
between like what I consider suppressive
and whether considers engagement
engaging I would say like you know micro
interventions and wearables should be
like you know not so high not so low
obtrusively speaking and you know they
are actually short in the engagement
party HSR shortly they died rather
quickly
you know the wearable the intervention
people use it and then they discard it
and they don't keep engaged for the long
term sorry we would say like you know
not just and and IOT might actually give
us a bit less obtrusiveness because you
know we're like not asking you to wear
anything and maybe we'll increase
engagement and of course if you get to
the point that we actually do like
implant saying configural environments
we will get to the point that you know
it might actually have higher engagement
because it's really in your body now but
it's arguable how you know at Rousset
this can be it's not clear
to design interventions to make right
you have to design interventions to get
people to use them and and deliver
values over the long term and that's
actually part of the challenge so in
this talk I'm gonna talk a bit more
about this subset of I would say like
you know the ecosystem of potential
interventions I'm not gonna talk a lot
about this one even though I I've done
some research but I want to discuss some
ideas on this area they're a concept
that I also want to bring you know as a
baseline of this conversation is this
idea of like you know what is health for
people like why do healthy people think
about health and the reality is like
healthy people were high level of health
don't really have a huge motivation to
stay or become healthy they are
motivated to be beautiful to be
interactive to be attractive to be smart
but they are nothing like oh I'm gonna
keep like my cardiovascular health
I'm gonna keep my like mental held up
today that's not how people think like
they think about the products of being
healthy not about health and themselves
and it's only when the cheerier ation
happens that people start really getting
like you know when you're hell double
goes down that motivation goes up and be
like okay now I really care about health
because something broke because
something is now going well so health
becomes fundamentally important but you
know precision health works with these
people and when I talk to my colleagues
in the med school is like these are not
patients right these are individuals
these are patients these are individuals
they have very different levels of
motivation therefore also very different
psychology so you cannot design the same
way that you design for these people or
these other ones over here and you know
what we hope is that you know we can
create engage in design to like you know
bring people to keep them healthy and
find this sweet spot between engagement
and efficacy you have to be efficacious
about sensing and about the
interventions that you deliver but you
have to also be engaging right and and I
call it a sweet spot because I think
it's like not a trivial way of finding a
very efficacious sensor intervention and
very engaging over the long term these
are challenging problems so one approach
I've taken you know through my
formation and
my research is like combining a few
philosophies to try to like do something
about us one is design thinking you know
for the creative aspects combine it with
the scientific method in order to
postulate hypotheses but once you have
also explore what are the needs of the
of the user in order to be creative but
also to have validated ways of sensing
and intervening right but you know for
those of you who have experience in both
ends these are not necessarily like the
philosophies are the people who practice
the philosophies don't necessarily mix
that well right these are like sadly
even though they shouldn't somehow they
just found themselves at odds many times
right in the way that they formulate
questions and problems I think we should
definitely train people to think in the
intersection of these things to create
these engaging and applications a sweet
spot I also used tools like machine
learning you know sometimes it's very
important I consider it more like an
aide rather than an objective even
though it's the emphasis right now is a
lot about machine learning but then the
other component that's also very
important to me is implementation right
there's a huge field that's nascent in
the public health realm called
implementation science right there's an
average of 17 years to get like a good
validated finding in the med school in
the actual market like 17 years even
though it's been validated for like many
many iterations so we're not really that
great at doing you know inter
implementation in the clinical world
much less implementation outside have in
the health domain in other domains are
very good like yeah Microsoft Google all
of you know how to implement products
that lead in the work for a long term
and that's what we're what we need to
like learn from each other
in order to keep doing like you know all
these like things and machine learning
helps us with the predictability and
implementation science with its
credibility so I'm going to tell you a
couple of like projects during this talk
one is the sensor licensing which is the
idea that I can like bring some ideas
that we created with sensing an AI bring
it from different domains like the
office into the car and
and eventually also get it to work
actually in a real car in a real
environment so we keep evolving towards
implementation and then this other
domain that we call the desert project
broad project in my lab is called subtle
interventions which started more in the
Design Thinking area got validated you
know in a simulator and now we're
actually have revalidated it on the road
see revalidation is a very interesting
word I'm gonna just make a small parent
this is if you go to the med school I
remember the first thing that I got
asked when I joined the med school like
almost two years ago is like how's your
thing being revalidated I'm like no
because you know Kai only wants us to
publish the monster innovative things
I'm like well once you revalidated three
times then we talk
that's a med school right they don't
just throw things that have not been
validated and revalidate for them for
them revalidated revalidation is very
important so anyways the procedure
helped design space for me also has
another challenge so combining those
those things I told you I think there's
two types of like tasks that you should
go to do procedure health one is the
exploration part and then the in debt
validation that we discussed but these
are two different types of people and
two different types of projects so in my
lab I have projects that I will consider
more like shallow and they are in the
creativity phase and I have people were
very creative but then I have projects
that are going depth and revalidate and
like redo study with very different type
of people for example this central is
sensing the type of person that I'm
hiring now is like an expert in bio bio
mechanical manipulation of the body he
doesn't know about design but he knows
exactly how the body moves because we're
revalidating the things that we have
been finding about that on or inside all
interventions also we're hiring people
who experts in like you know machine
learning and IOT to deliver the
interventions well I have designers and
other people doing that thing so the
combination of these two things I think
it makes the lab very interesting makes
it also hard to manage
rights are very complicated lab to
management because you have people were
like let's scratch the surface a lot
like as long as you don't prove this I
will never believe what you're telling
me so it's a very interesting creative
tension let's call it that way and I
think you know Mike Rosario is one of
those places where you also find a lot
of these things super exciting so very
briefly I've about me chest for the sake
of you know explaining why am I doing
this thing where I come from you know I
I gave up you know my business career
because of family experience in mental
health and I've been studying mental
health ever since I joined the PhD at
Berkeley and now I'm doing what I like
this well-being in precision health but
I'm a CS PhD working in a med school so
that's an interesting combination right
I was hired to be part of this new
center called the presidential health
and integrated diagnostic centers abroad
center where my lab resides and it's
about trying to discuss these problems
like how do we design new things how do
we do the behavioral economics aspect
how do we do the economic about
economics of adoption of like proactive
health and it's a very very new like way
of thinking for the med school they are
learning how to do even with me like
like we still don't understand you that
well but we're starting to get something
out of you just to clarify when I say
well-being is a very broad topic there's
a lot of things so what I'm gonna do is
over seem oversimplified tremendously in
the and in the focus of for this talk
and talk mostly about stress management
that's naba all means what well-being
means well-being is a very complicated
large construct that's been discussed in
many ample terms in public health but
I'm gonna focus on the stress management
so so let me tell you about stress
management as an operationalization of
life or the research that I do so
remember all these people that I showed
you know they they went through all
these things so what do these have in
common right I don't know if you can
help me find something that's common you
know if you if you look at them whether
they are like you know happy or angry or
whatever
most of these people also suffer of
stress or arousal arousal economic
arousal though it's a driver for like
pretty much on any other emotion and the
truth is that stress right now it's
becoming a really complicated problem in
America
alone is 300 billion dollars 80% of
adults have reported to have issues with
stress and not being able to deal with
the stress and it basically affects any
part of your life like if you read the
fine print something's gonna break in
your body if you talk to so an internist
or internal medicine person will tell
you like something's gonna break we
don't know yet what's gonna break and
that's something that we have to
actually start understanding better with
more sensing but there's another
commonality also across these people I
don't know if you can spot what else is
common across all these pictures here
something specific No well these people
are indoors so we became an indoor
species we were not designed to be
indoor species look at our arms and our
legs we're runners gatherers hunters
were like designed to move and we spend
ourselves sitting right so you wanna
find a human find a chair right there
easy
so 93% of the time indoors that means
that this is not our new ecosystem so
you know at the end of the day we have
to attack stress in its ecosystem so
anyways
stress you know is this very interesting
thing that we talked about like
challenge and thread and you know how
can we cope with that thing can we do it
that's how our body produces resources
and he gets like tens because we're not
you know mammals and we produce like
muscle tension to get out you know we
have the year it's Dodson law that tells
us that we need some level of stress not
too much not too little to operate and
you know it's been proven mostly with
animals and a little bit with with
humans and Sapolsky that tells us that
you know stress is very useful and
zebras don't get ulcers because they use
it very well once the lion come they are
the zebra runs and you know that helps
your metabolism to basically dissipate
stress and that's exactly what it was
designed but the truth is that you know
these cycles of like stress and distress
stress and distress which are very
normal in modern times because of the
frequency of the stressors they are
becoming actually a problem because of
these repetitive stress
to regenerate our outer immune system
and other types of problem so at the end
of the day we you know a stress is
something that needs to be managed not
eliminated right it has to be managed
part of life's part of support may I
have a question another question for you
so we have the zebra that runs and you
know that doesn't get ulcers but what
are the zebra need to be able to
actually do and be efficient with the
use of stress pretty without the Prairie
the poor zebra might actually die of a
heart attack if the lion comes and
there's nowhere to run
oh that so you know stress management in
the wild works because there's this pace
because you move because that's what we
do when we're stressed we get tense our
muscles get jacked up to defend with a
fight-or-flight but look at our modern
wild at 93% of our times we spend in
these environments right so where do we
run how do we move how do we manage our
stress in these things so then you will
have a philosophical conversation oh
let's get out and those do exercise I'm
like sure fantastic now you spend 93
percent of your time here so you're
basically designing for the seven
percent oh we want to convert these
people okay if you're super successful
say you convert 99 9% 10% of those 93
percent still you have 80 percent people
who basically do this every day so why
don't we redesign these spaces to do a
stress management in the wild this is
the new world this is our wild people
would say no no that's not no we have to
get out of offices no just accept it
suck it up offices are the new wire for
humans simple let's the redesign them to
make them like you know viable to do a
stress management the problem is that
you know right now stress management
it's really like very lame like you know
there's a lot of stress-related visits
to the primary care and only very few
get some support from primary care like
almost nothing they don't know where how
to do
it's true they send you with an Advil
for your headache right if you say well
then the mental health wear has to be
taken care of so mental health we say
one quarter of population has issue the
truth is that about 10 percent of them
them get referred to a some kind of like
supporting institution 20 percent of
those get diagnosed with something
one-third of those complete treatment
and one-third of those do not relapse so
if you compute this like beautiful like
cascade you had a tremendously an
efficient system for mental health
doesn't work either we say okay not on a
wait a minute it stress the zebra
doesn't go to the doctor is your problem
so why don't you deal with that that's
put it back on the user so what do the
user says so you know at the end of the
day what do you think are the two major
reasons for lack of good stress
management in the new wild time lack of
willpower and lack of time yeah and
these are like you know a large cohort
of a thousand people that APA did yeah
so we're also very bad at managing
there's no time so we need support we
need support so for me this mundane
stress management is like I'm gonna take
the the bull by the horns and like I'm
gonna design for the 93% of the time
that you spend in these places offices
cars and homes and I'm gonna try to see
a way if I can do a make a chair into
something that works for a stress or a
table or a lamp or something that's
already there and then learn from each
other
so so let's start with with with these
two environments first the office in the
home to tell you some of the things that
we've been thinking and doing and then
I'll tell you more about the car so this
was the first study that you know
inspired some of the work we actually
published this paper a few years ago and
like can we sense stress just by the way
you move the mouse this is a five dollar
mouse from Walmart no sensors at it just
look at the way you move x and y and
then try to create a biomechanical model
of the arm
which gets affected by muscle tension
because that's the the normal reaction
and proved in the damping frequency of a
mass spring damper model of that thing
will actually increase because it's
correlated with the K coefficient of
your muscle tension and we proved that
and we show that you know it is possible
to do that we actually what we did is we
created a bunch of like punt but bunch
of tasks like point and click or drag
and drop or steering and we replicated
essentially the Fiedler experiment and
then we show that for every combination
of distance and width for different
targets we were able to actually find a
difference in a stress and no stress
this is the mean without necessarily
there are bars and you're actually able
with about ten random samples and a
simple machine learning classifier
together already seventy percent
accuracy with a very simple tool which
is damping frequency and the way that we
did that is using a tool that we borrow
from speech processing the linear
predictive coding in order to do the
generation of an old poll model of your
arm and try to establish what is the the
major component of oscillation of your
arm that's how we created this thing at
the end of the day you know this is very
simple you know it's just software it's
really not heavy in any way and it can
be implemented in about four billion
mouths that are already deployed in the
world like PC Mouse five dollar from
Walmart right we also recently moved and
did studies replicated same study for
touchpad now touchpad is a very
interesting problem it's way more
complicated the mouse it has the
extremely complication in the way that
people use with two fingers with two
hands in different ways also the arm and
the fingers are way more complicated
there I'm sorry the the hand and the
wrist and the fingers are way more
complicated in an arm and it requires
like more analysis but we were happy to
find that for all the conditions all the
combinations of distances and widths we
found actually a difference in one of
the features which was the area under
the finger so the amount of like let's
say as a proxy for pressure the area
the finger seems to be clearly
correlated with the amount of stress
that you have for touchpads and where
this papers in submission right now oh
these are the values actually so we got
people to stress with a stressor like
doing math and then we measure the level
of stress and then we basically show
that is area under the finger worked and
right now we're actually working we're
very proud we got approval to implement
our technology both the mouse and the
trackpad in a clinic in the Hoover
Hoover pavilion is one of the clinic
family medicine clinics so right now
burnout is one that huge problem in the
Med medical domain where now there's a
prevalence of higher than 50% I'm not
going to spend a lot of time but
essentially we're now there's a
combination of stress and dehumanization
and the humanization happens because of
the cycle of production for new patients
to be treated so doctors don't have the
time to develop an empathetic
interaction and that dehumanization
let's call it that way
generates a lot of like emotional traits
and stress so we're going to be using
the mouse and also the trackpad and all
the computers that practitioners are
doing and where this is going to be
longitudinal in this high risk
population now one of the interventions
that we're actually testing right now to
try to modulate stress is how do we
enable movement right so movement is in
or what that's whether the the zebras
one way of looking at movement is the
the past 50 years of studies incident
tourism have been focused in what's
called moderate to like active movement
but now more recently there's a new
trend to try to look at what's called
the low intensity physical activity the
leaper that means like even like
changing posture or moving a little bit
it's predictive of your mortality so
what we implemented was this desk that
we call the haunted s that basically
that thing that moves on its own and the
reason we created these robotic death
which I know it's not look silly it's
because you
no basically sorry we investigated that
70% of users who start doing these days
remain sitting after three months so
after three months nobody uses this
instant desk anymore just sitting there
and then you ask them why and it turns
out that you know about like 70% say
like forgot apathy I'm like okay so if
you don't care then I'm gonna start
moving it for you and see what happens
so we basically did our early analysis
of you know what is the reaction that
you have to Emanuel versus in an
autonomic desk within a small cohort of
20 people and we probe to see how they
felt about their stress and thing and we
found no differences between the two
they do become very interesting very
interestingly they become very
opinionated at the end when you say like
give me a reason between the two they
will tell you very strong reasons about
like I don't want to be remove the
control how does a desk there to tell me
what to do and you know I want to have
control but when they are doing the
thing you would see people like
literally sitting and then going up and
I didn't pay attention to the desk so
we're going to test these like concept
of what we call non volitional behavior
change we're going to force you to move
no persuasion anymore we're going to
push in the limit like number - no - see
we can get you moving and we want to do
it in longitudinal we're going to start
a longitudinal study now in January and
we'll report back you know we hope that
you know we can train a neural network
that's very adaptable very good that's
actually in our brain did your network
to basically get you used to go up and
down without like you know complaining
anymore right as opposed to training a
super advanced machine learning thing to
find the perfect time to move the desk
there's some papers I have already
investigated this it's a very
complicated problem you want to make it
perfect it just doesn't work so we're
going to go and in your face just move
it and see if humans get used to that so
that's one of the movement things that
we're trying the other one that we're
trying is like can we actually regulate
breathing in a very like peripheral way
it should not be called subliminally
peripheral peripheral way we're
developing this basically
is a plug-in that activates a breathing
edge around your browser that's linked
to your breathing rate and as you start
like you know getting stressed it tries
to bring it down to the same level and
it's very powerful you keep working you
barely notice the thing and we already
have collected like some preliminary
data that actually people do keep a
lower breathing rate chest by the
exposure to this very soothing frequency
of the peripheral vision we're actually
right now investigating what's the right
application because if you study the the
the visual cortex the peripheral vision
actually has a stronger connection to
your parasympathetic nervous system as
opposed to the the foveal vision the
part of the peripheral vision is has a
stronger connection so there's a huge
potentially we can activate the
periphery stimulus you might actually
have a great chance so we think that
this will be even stronger you have
bigger monitors you know where you would
really activate your peripheral vision
as opposed to like smaller ones or maybe
in the car as well you know maybe in the
thing you need to we need to work with
your rods the rods not with the cones
right the cones are the ones that
basically gets you alerted and like kind
of aroused the rods can help you calm
down the other thing that we have been
doing you know is like this intervention
sweets this is actually the work that we
work with Mary here the the the the puff
therapy right how do we do this micro
interventions that was the early
exploration of this thing can we get on
a stressor and use some kind of
contextual information to provide a
recommendation of very mundane things I
remember we went on and say like we're
gonna pick the most mundane things but
the ones that are popular though so we
went on and look at the very popular
things that use online that you already
know how to use so I'm not going to
teach you anything new I'm just going to
get you going to do exactly the same
things that you do and how do we like
recommend with a machine learning tool
what is the best thing to do at certain
point we created and sorry for the
busyness this is part of our paper we
created a suite of interventions that
basically were essentially two parts a
prompt and a link and we say like go do
this in facebook like for example one of
them was like
go and look at your like time line and
just look at a good part of your your
life and that's actually highly
correlated with the three good things
technique that you seen in in positive
psychology so we found actually we work
with the clinical psychology to find an
intersection between the popular apps
that popular mundane apps with popular
techniques in psychology and it's
amazing actually many of these things I
would say people I would say they are
using it already with a purpose of like
stress management right without them
necessarily calling them that way we
will use a bunch of things from the
phone in order to train our contextual
bandit and try to basically deliver
these things over time and we were we
ran out for weeks you know with a bunch
of like some things that we did daily
weekly etc and we did this construct of
2x2 between random and machine learning
recommendation and also the possibility
to select or not select and we
eventually saw that you know there was a
lot of personalization that happened
across all these different interventions
with all the different participants we
had like I we started with like 80 or
something winded up with at 27 right or
I'm not remembering so that dropout was
equivalent to to what you see in other
apps but you know we saw like there was
personalization and if you see an
aggregate of these we we basically the
random recommendation was this versus
this is what we ended up at the odd week
for after training several times the
context of and contextual bandit and the
funny parts that when you asked them
separately to people which ones they
preferred they were highly correlated
with the ones that the the algorithm
picked for themselves - one thing that
we observed was very important was this
novelty effect this graphs a bit busy
but and also pay attention to the scale
turns out that you know people started
testing for those who were in the
selection
section they were testing new apps I
wanted to explore
instead of like exploit after a while
they started becoming a bit more like
used to like you know what they were you
receive from the algorithm but after two
weeks they started again exploring
exploring experience program like what
happened we supposedly already
identified the best interventions for
you but now you're not happy why not
then we did interview a couple and they
say like I'm bored yeah okay breathing
is good for me moving like doing Yasha
what else is there out that's a huge
challenge I would say for in the wild
design the boredom a novelty is really a
complicated problem that needs to be
attacked and I think it can be done
systemically with algorithms as well the
other thing that we found very
interesting was this paradox you know
many people who dropped early in the
study dropped because they said your app
stresses me up I'm like no way there's a
stress management I'm supposed to help
you not to stress you up they say well
the thing is that once I installed that
thing in my in my phone I keep being
reminded that I had the stupid app and
reminds me of my stress and how I stress
I am and I'm like so awareness for
stress management is not trivial
everybody thinks aware this is the
beginning of all health interventions I
disagree
for stress you have to be very careful
awareness can actually be an accessor
Bayesian factor we have to be very good
how you design these things so one of
the extensions of the work that we did
with Mary is this idea of puppets this
is what we got funding from the human
center AI movement in Stanford so we're
actually doing a similar idea but with
micro chatbots and what we're trying to
do is basically create a family of
chocolates because those could not
understand their will they the word of
like childhood development for mental
health it's being very hard the lies
that at first you know mental health
Chadwell was created in the 50's what
happened 70 years and we haven't cracked
the nut it's not a trivial problem to do
because you know it's very hard to keep
track of all the complexity of life and
mental health basically about life so
what we did is we proposed to work
together with dan jurafsky who is my my
my
researcher a professor in linguistics
it's like let's create a bunch of ups a
bunch of micro childhoods and then then
let's create a recommendation layer that
will recommend the childhood that works
for you for the different like you know
context and see we can find a posse of
chatbots that will work for you and
discard those who don't work for you so
in that case you can actually like you
know do some kind of like trimming we
basically started with a wizard or a bus
to validate if this idea of having
multiple chapel works and we basically
had variable several Chad Watts versus
control which was one single chat board
and people found that you know sorry
this should have been the other way
around people found that you know having
multiple childhoods actually a bit more
useful than having a single childhood we
that's the very beginning when we
started with a wizard of us simulation
but then ever since we actually deploy
the app that we created in telegram and
we basically did it where we applied
most of the money in creating this app
that basically developed the delivers
this this BOTS and we have been testing
it with students with non students and
now we're going to do a larger cohort
we've observed that you know most of the
stressors that people report when they
talk to the bots are about to work in
school and productivity and some with
relationships etc so we need to learn to
like you know identify the things and
the other thing that we observed is that
by you know asking them was it helpful
or neutral we are right now like in a
complicated points because we there's
people who find the bots useful but
there's also people who didn't find the
work the bots useful in this but we
start investigating we realize that you
know there is very important problems
here that need to be attended especially
from the NLP perspective one of them is
parsing of the stress or when the you
ask when the bot asks like how are you
doing what you're stressful and somebody
says like I'm stressed because I'm
running late and you know I might get
fired or maybe get like you know
punished or something what is the stress
order is it that you're late or that
you're might be get laid or a compounded
of those two and if you understand how
to parse and basically talk back at the
user exactly what the stressor is
the empathy that the rapport builds up
immediately like oh that the but
understands me if you just say oh sorry
sorry you're stressed it's very rough
the interaction so parsing a stressor
from an open text question it's not
trivial because the knowledge domain of
stressors is huge
so we're working on trying to construct
a very large database to try to start
parsing these stressors in a much more
efficient way from an NLP perspective
the other one is we have to answer this
question can I provide support sometimes
people want to use these chat BOTS even
though they are designed for daily
stress management for things like you
know like my son
you know it's suicidal and wants to like
very complicated problems now those
level of attention of treatment cannot
be dealt with like a simple childhood
that only gives you simple therapeutic
advice those should be escalated so we
need to determine in terms of severity
and complexity can we support and
basically escalate those where we can
and the other one is that's very
important we cannot just launch this
system in a random way like we launched
the pub therapy improv therapy we
launched literally with our random you
know assignment like traditional
contextual bandit and people kept trying
here they create a very strong you know
connection to the very first
conversation so the very first
conversation with the user the very
first bot that a test is not great
that's pretty much the end of the of the
engagement so you cannot just start with
a random based on one so we're creating
a free train run recommendation based
for this problem the other thing that we
did with the puppet that I think it's
just work quickly sharing is we did some
qualitative analysis and what we did is
this card sorting technique where we
asked them to like take some cards that
look like you know with the stressors in
them and try to ask them to like put
them in different boxes that had a
different but so I said like for example
what kind of blood do you want for
financial problems oh I want the problem
solving one what do you want from
relationship one eye one the humor one
and we asked them to distribute them and
to talk about that and that was all very
interesting but then the part that's
more interesting about the whole thing
is that you know we then added humans
and we say okay let's say you have
humans and BOTS and you have humans
always available so forget about
availability redistribute the cards
after they have done the bot and they
don't didn't put everyone in the human
side they left some in the bot side I
mean like why are you leaving but humans
aren't aren't humans supposed to be
better to provide support and all that
like yeah but no sometimes they are not
better sometimes they take too long to
give you advice sometimes they are like
I have to like engage and go through all
these like conversations chess to tell
them what's going on sometimes I don't
trust them they want BOTS in their lives
people want these BOTS as part of an
ecosystem of support so that's why we're
trying to work with these ecosystem the
delays part is fascinating we also
tested we learned when we were doing
this like qualitative assessment they
told us we want the bot to have a delay
I said why do you need a delay I'm like
well you know the promise that I send my
my stress during like immediately
responds back to me and I there's other
people who have seen this before too
like but it's a pot it's already
processed do you know two milliseconds I
know it doesn't matter I know but still
I need the body to feel human so that
need to have delays and feel human is a
very interesting one some of them wanted
to use multiple BOTS they say I don't
want you one but I want to start first
calming myself down and then I go into
problem-solving and then maybe I do some
breathing regulation the human body was
a very interesting one this was love and
hate relationship some people love the
humor one it was like a simple joke type
of thing and so people hated it with
their whole hearts it's like how do you
dare to try to make me laugh when I'm
stressed like don't do that ever in your
life and now we're testing also this in
formal language we're testing what if we
actually add lol's and little faces and
like sup and instead of how are you
doing is like what's up man type of
thing again very devices younger people
find it kind of cute and interesting old
people older people oh my god there was
one person work
got very upset with you lol like how is
this boss
but like saying lol at me I'm stressed
it stupid but you know so these little
things we're investigating we
linguistical and tried to design an
interesting platform that combines the
HCI design with NLP problems and try to
deliver this microbots
we're also investigating the voice part
but in the voice part the voice version
of these BOTS we found a very
interesting problem like and maybe
there's a solution like I haven't
investigated deeper enough so we did it
actually in a Whizzer a bust format in
the car
these pauses that people make when they
are closed so how are you feeling and
like well um you know it's been hard you
know I have all this from all that like
you know searching for the reasons on
how to spread your emotions that are
very natural for humans to make pulses
you break this voice interfaces
immediately like try to express your
feelings to Alexa
or to any other things you know and tell
me your theory or anybody it's tell me
if they can actually understand that you
are not done talking very complicated is
and we try to do phonetics and proxemics
and other things English is a very
complicated one seems like Japanese is
more doable Japanese seems to have like
some process of the inflection that will
tell you that you're not done or done
but English is all over the place so
where that's that's one of the things
that we will be working in the future
can we actually also find a solution
well with a lot of data we might be able
to train our deep neural networks on but
we don't have a lot of data for stress
management in the way and the last thing
that we're doing right now just says
that mostly as you know the future of
what we're doing is we're actually
combining stress and productivity as
well so one of the challenges with
healthy people as I said like stress is
not enough work watched why do I have to
manage my stress for what and one of the
key challenges is productivity so we're
really bringing together some of the
knowledge that we have created with
sensors and some of the knowledge that
Michael Bernstein and his team has
created with habit lab this is a new
tool that they created to do
procrastination management only
exclusively procrastination but
procrastination is
very emotional problem they haven't
touched the affected component of
procrastination they only basically give
you tools that basically block Facebook
or like delay Facebook and so some of
these times actually these behavioral
interventions work but the thing is that
procrastination is emotional I mean if
you think about a procrastination is
really almost like none logical like how
why will you procrastinate if it's going
to hurt you hurt yourself so it's very
emotional that the psychology behind is
coming so we're combining the habit lab
learning with the pub therapy stress
management and papads in trying to
create like an interesting like you know
probe of a stress and productivity habit
luck has already like 12,000 users and
we're like working with these people and
they have like 50 new users every day
being recorded for this plug-in that
they created alright so that was the
office let me tell you a little bit
about the car so the car why the car
though
like so actually it's not about the car
I'm gonna skip this one we already went
this it's not the cards that commute the
commutes are very interesting problems
so remember there's no time to deal with
stress well that's because you're
running and working that commutes one of
those times when people actually don't
really have a very strong opinion of
like their time years it's like will you
do a breathing exercise in the commune
yeah probably yeah would you do
something yeah I'm not working I'm not
either at home I'm transitioning well
the commutes are very interesting thing
because in the US people are spending
cars 60 minutes a day every single day
on average this is a hundred and twenty
eight million people that jump in a car
every single day 87 percent of the labor
force commute by car in this country
this is 128 million hours no x 2 hours
per day so this is like a lot of
opportunity 114 million of those commute
alone by themselves in a car
can we do something to confer to
transform the commute which is for many
a bug in life into a feature again you
know I'm like taking the bull by the
horns on like a commute yeah sucks well
let's do something about it right how
can we use a commute to break the
exacerbation chain between office and
home you know to do work-life balance
and basically create the opportunities
that we want to do that so again doing
the centrally sensing and subtle
interventions we actually did the same
studies that we did for the mouse were
in the car and also we've been dealing
with like breathing regulation in the
car so the sensor the sensor part is
essentially an extension of the what we
said before like you know we can use
these beautiful sensors for movement in
the car there's this movement for the
upper limbs and for the lower limbs and
they are already being encoded pretty
much the drive wire by wire cards
modern-day backward they all have
encoders already you can actually go and
buy an obd and onboard diagnostics USB
from like online and get like data out
of your car in no time so how do we
repurpose this car and and the reason is
that we're also doing the same type of
approach that we had before in the in
the car instead of looking at the
autonomic nervous system analysis we're
looking at a somatic nervous system
analysis by looking at how you move
things that's how we basically approach
this problem this is a traditional
psychophysiology that you can get in a
car as well and this is what we think we
can add value like looking at movement
from your neck your shoulder your legs
your arms and converted into an
unobtrusive stress sensor so what we did
is we basically started with a simulator
study because you never know the effects
of stress so we got people driving and
we monitor essentially your turns right
there are anything that's positive is a
right turn anything that's negative is a
left turn and we got them we basically
wanted to do the mass spring damper
model again but this time with like
angular movement and we put people in
both stress and and and and calm
conditions
the stress condition is a bit peculiar
though because in the mouse you can get
like a hundred clicks in like about a
few minutes you can add a hundred you
cannot get a hundred turns in a few
minutes in a car so you have to stress
them up but then you have to strain the
stress so what we did is we did applied
math not the same that we did in the
other one and then we apply heavy-metal
during the drive and this is actually a
former yeah there is actually a very
interesting journal psychophysiology
paper that shows that heavy metal is
actually pretty stressful for ninety
percent of the population and very
calming for another ten percent all
right so the experiment was like you
know 25 people you do the baseline with
a video then you calm them down then you
do the driving thing and you know
counterbalance everything and as I said
you know we have math but also heavy
metals to keep the stress high while
you're like driving there were a couple
of like old ladies or we all skill them
without having and they said is the
worst experience of my life I have never
had something like that again damping
free is the damper in frequency gonna
change we use this advance simulator for
driving that basically had high
frequency high sampling rate to try to
get a more precise reading and we on
purpose didn't put any type of traffic
or any type of other stimulus because
otherwise you will be stimulating other
components of the somatic nervous system
so simply a driving learning curve and
what we did is we basically did a simple
analysis we took the turns we got the
absolute values then we found the peaks
and look at the monotonically increasing
segments of turn and then we basically
picked the first part of each segment
the was you know in a turn because
that's the first part when the intention
occurs with your muscles the first few
degrees after that there is other other
forces that influence the movement
including the the the the movement of
the wheel itself so we wanted to keep
the very first part of the of the
movement which has a stronger you know a
muscular activation and then we apply
the same technique
for the order linear predictive coding
which is a speech technique speech
processing technique to predict the
second-order mass spring damper we look
at basically what's called the under
damped poles which is the stable you
know poles over the system and we were
able to predict the damping frequency
correctly we validated that stress that
people got very stressed we measure also
the pleasure our elements and as you can
see people really hated the heavy metal
like really badly and here this yeah we
basically proved that damping frequency
also works and we published this paper
in KY last year this is the fast and
furious paper there's a title of the
paper the beautiful thing that we also
found that we didn't need ten minutes of
driving which was more or less what we
did to get like a la with about eight
turns we were able to also see already a
signal with the first eight turns so
that means that you know even when
you're like just moving out of a parking
lot and getting into a highway where
it's more stable you might still get be
able to detect something and we also
simulated we decimated the signal in
order to get a lower sampling frequency
because the OBD that you get the signal
is that sample that a thousand Hertz
like the simulator that we did is
usually about around twenty to fifty
Hertz so we wanted to see if it works
with like decimation and it worked well
as well
we chose replicated these in the wild
and we are like should be published in
in would soon and you become we did it
in the garage or under the office where
we work we work in the theranos building
with Elizabeth Hong Jisoo
so we moved there we took over he had
not to do with Tara knows it's just the
left over of that building so we use
this because since it was abandoned
world abandon its remodel that this was
the first lab of the med school in that
building and we're very proud to say
where they we have the first lab which
is a garage with a car and we proved
that it actually works also very well in
the wild and we're like submitting this
my my my postdoc did it we're gonna skip
this one so that's essentially with a
sense of the sensing part now on the
subtle interventions part
how much life okay so in the cellar
interventions we started testing like
will people actually do movement in the
car well as you can see I'm obsessed
with movement and we saw that you know
can we guide them with like you know a
chair that has a bunch of like mothers
to cogno to like do things like guide
you like it's a swap swipe up and down
like to see if you can bend or do twists
and things by activating these motors we
wanted you to do like side stretches or
head turns or or or other things and
eventually the one that really worked
was their breathing they want they will
do guided breathing with this type of
chair like that the chair basically
tells you when to breathe in and when to
breathe out and they basically said
that's what I want to do deep breathing
and maybe other types of breathing like
sigh breathing like tell me when to sigh
and things like that so so we went on
that that was an exploratory study and
we basically did it breathing I was
going to ask you to like take a 10
second deep breathing so you can feel
the power of the breathing so we can do
like 10 second deep breathing and see
like how do you feel
let's do it together so I can also take
apart
so see deep breathing is pretty soothing
right even ten seconds the problem is
that it's really soothing to the point I
can't get you to sleep so you're driving
though we don't want that so we actually
wanted to test it can be done while
driving so we basically got people
driving and breathing slowly and we saw
that you know we can go from nineteen to
eleven breaths per se per minute in
about forty seconds with the guidance
which is not bad you know it helps you
like reduce your breathing rate and
chest with our simple guidance on your
back I was going to explain you know the
reason of like deep breathing is because
it modulates basically your oxygenation
and also your respiratory sinus
arrhythmia that's how breathing
regulates stress and we focused mostly
on ongoing from normal to about thirty
percent below normal now really deep
breathing is considered to be around six
breaths per minute when you're really
good and the benefits are fantastic but
you really have to be very good to do
that thing you many people actually like
cannot do very very deep breathing so we
want we focus on only the early part
which is the 30% reduction and we tested
several interactions you know an
accordion like interaction or a counter
like interaction or spear alone
interaction to see which one or just one
a counter that basically tells you and
eventually most people prefer a very
simple interest a swipe that goes up and
a swipe that goes down so I'm like the
other ones but this metaphor was the
best one the one that we picked we
implemented that and we basically got
people like you know linked to your
breathing rate and we contrasted it with
a voice-activated single like you know
the car you're driving the car tells you
breathe in breathe out breathe in
breathe out talk to you we ran this
study in the city and also in the
highway and we tested the haptic versus
it what is the reason we you do this and
career research is because cities and
highways are very different places to
test any of these things and then you
have you know typical baseline and then
the different conditions and then you
basically cut the counterbalance this
thing I'm gonna skip this design
period so this is the the apparatus
where the person was monitoring the
person and this is the result so we had
people that reduced their breathing rate
while they were exposed to this the the
guidance but also after they were left
the guidance was turned off that was
pretty cool so you turn off the guidance
and they remain breathing slowly now the
voice was rather heavy also started a
bit higher the baseline right but it was
a with better than ethic but the
sustained effect of the haptic is a bit
more like flat it was a bit more
sustained in the other one so both of
them worked I wouldn't say that I have
to beat the other one both of them work
they both work and they both reduce also
her availability or increase in this
case right there are MSSD
I think the other the other element is
also to test well
sure your brilliance no but are you are
you gonna get in that accident so we
measure two element safety and
performance I want there's a difference
between safety performance and car
safety means that can you die
performance like you suck at driving you
can still suck a driving and drive but
not be in a place of like so we didn't
find any safety issues and we found that
people perceive the haptic to be less
distracting and we probe that a little
bit like you know what do you prefer
they say I prefer happy this is their
preferences because it's less
cognitively demanding means that you
know that I don't use my part for
anything the other one I have to be
paying attention and it's also easy to
reengage this was fascinating they
basically say like I'm driving and I
don't want to bridge so I just pulled
myself before where I don't need to feel
that thing do mine my new Varuna and
then I go back ok now I can keep
continue they prefered guidance over
over chess a prompt a notch they said no
neither one a notch I want you to keep
telling me how to breathe because
otherwise I get confused and I keep
driving and I don't do it and they found
better it many other like you know
subjective like easy to use efficacious
etc and yeah some people say well I
prefer that you put this in a highway
not when I'm turning right or when I'm
like in a red light or something like
that that would be good one side effect
of this breathing was
we tested also autonomous driving so we
also had the autonomous driving and look
at this guy 40 seconds in and he's lippy
badly sleepy so if you don't have level
5 automation don't put these things that
I was telling the mercedes-benz people
though we're gonna put it like do you
have level 5 out to mention in your cars
no it's like they don't do it because
you might kill people with this thing
you will put them to sleep very quickly
so we actually also tested well what
happens if we breathe faster than can we
wake people up and we have a paper that
actually shows that we can wake people
up by getting you to breathe faster so
we're working with a truck company now
to try to like improve performance and
we tested it in the same garage this is
a different cohort different even like
circuit and we tested it and we proved
it that it actually works yeah I'm gonna
skip a little bit but basically we are
tested you know the control versus now
we use a control and the intervention
work really well and this is for non
conscious breathing right so its
replication of the other one but we also
did it stress intervention so we stress
them up and then we verify if we can
reduce you're after a stressor can we
reduce your brain already it actually
works even better when when I stress
will spread so I can bring your non
conscious brain rate low I can really
bring you down back from a stressor in
the car so anyways this is the summary
of what you can do in a car they
commutes a beautiful thing so it's not
really about the cars the commute is
such a great opportunity to do something
in the mundane world to really like do
not obtrusive sensing and interventions
you know I have a bunch of projects that
you can see I'm not going to go through
all of them but they are all in the
realm of design science and
implementation and machine learning we
have like six eight people working in my
lab right now we're very excited of like
you know finding other collaborations
with many of you it will be really nice
and you know we want to keep repurposing
things you know we did something happier
with Mary as well
can we actually add some sensors and
then make it better these were already
Microsoft products like I would like
what happened like let's find them again
right you
do cool stuff with the capacitive
sensing mouse you can do cool stuff with
like pressure sensing like you know very
useful and and and you know I just told
you about these like extreme behavior
change that you know I'm very interested
one of the things that I wanted to close
with is some of these ideas of like
behavior change are very interesting to
me one of them is this like number leash
not behavior change but the other one is
like can I do it subliminally can I get
your breathing rate to be changed
subliminally so you sit in a chair you
feel nothing and your breathing rates
modulated and we're doing that with
what's called a low-frequency transducer
or also known as a bad kicker so we're
using this bad kicker to generate these
very low frequencies that basically uses
your tour acts as a resonance box to try
to generate changes in your pattern of
like breathing and we're putting them in
both the car and also in the office and
we're trying to use this concept of an
Train and it's a very powerful concept
entrainment means an external stimulus
induces an intersection change in your
body you can do that with light with
haptics we tapping with different
rhythmic patterns and and and we're also
using these other kinds of synchrony try
to do biomimetics so the chair feels
like a living animal
Greggy breeds like a living animal so
it's like you know this mammal
connection then and we're investigating
how to determine the liminal level of
haptics right so psycho haptics is less
studied in psychoacoustics but it's
possible to find liminal levels of
perception and still generate and I'm
actually pretty excited to show like
preliminary data we actually had the
subliminal this is a subliminal
condition we were testing like you know
baseline superluminal subliminal control
subliminal less subliminal let's call it
and superluminal and the subliminal I
had the lowest zero point to the lowest
level that you feel nothing
below your liminal level had the highest
effect on your breathing rate this is
this happening across four out of five
participants so far so we're very
excited we're creating now experiment
these works that means that I can create
the chairs that will basically modulate
your breathing rate without you having
to do
anything I just sit on the thing right
and this one I already went through so
thank you so much for your attention
I wanted to remind you that I focus on
these nudges but there's these other
whole world of micro interventions but I
think at the end of the day we should
all work in an ecosystem right it is an
ecosystem of intervention and try to
like create recommendation systems to
try to manage that to have this high
engagement and high efficacy the sweet
spot that we're looking for right across
multiple scenarios and across like you
know multiple types of like people
people who like exploring you know as
you can see I was gonna you know
basically show you many of my projects
are here but some of them are here and
don't shy away from complexities where I
keep telling my people in the med
schools like you've been operating on
this side for like 30 years
some people operate on that one we'll
have a parade in the chasm I just need
to be fed from both sides though this
has the science and the other side to
try to create what I call this precision
healthy engineering combining design
engineering medicine and that's that's
my talk thank you so much appreciate it
[Applause]
I would love it if you can back up one
slide because I wanted to take a photo
there's so much on there yes so for
driving I I tend to get more stressed as
I'm driving yeah and the extremity setup
that you have is you know stress right
at the beginning how are you so we just
completed collecting this oh okay so
that question of what is the the the
natural expression of stress in a car
without any stressor is something needs
to be documented Healey and picard did
something in the past but they also did
some simulation we are trying to collect
very natural natural istic data so we
just collected sixteen people driving
for 45 minutes around so Stanford's has
some city but then there's some
mountains and then there's highway that
280 in the back so we got him to drive
to three different scenarios and where
we both serve is like yeah some people
get stressed as the drive continues some
people actually get can't as the drug
continued some people find driving
soothing so that's in the very important
thing that needs to be observed what's
the the baselines not stable right
there's so we need to control for that
we have not control for that in these
experiments so now that we're basically
generate the data to establish your
baseline we will have to control for
that kind of like variation and see you
know maybe I don't need to do anything
to just let you drive or maybe you have
to be very careful how like manipulate
their stress if you're already stressed
and top of that put heavy metal and I
get your stress you might actually get
to a point that you will be completely
overwhelmed and not only from a
perspective of like designing
interventions also from a methodological
perspective because we want to move to
like people driving in cars yeah this
thing they're testing in a real car with
a real person it's very complicated we
provide insurance we provide all those
things but that's the lives are
absolutely important so where where
right now establishing that baseline
with empirical information you know but
thanks for the point yeah mm-hmm
I'm just a bracelet that's great then
you're like would you imagine was you
know what the baseline is yeah to eat
the kind of breathing kind of out of
nowhere and that's a very complicated
question I mean see that's the thing I
mean so I can measure things about your
body like movement and muscle tension
and you know there's all these other
wearable like you know gauges an expert
in doing this things like we can measure
a bunch of like very concrete things
about your body but then you have the
subjective component right
whether precise or not it's it's it's
powerfully important because it drives
behavior right like your mindset your
beliefs and your core preferences try
behavior so if I measure something
that's going on like say like you know
your HIV is going up I need you to move
but you don't feel like you know
subjectively or like no I'm fine
would the person move will they get I
know it with a thing right I think you
know the the study of like trying to
understand these micro interventions
boils down to understanding these
complexity of the two sides and trying
to like bring all together in a more
complex model but I think there's also
the need to like understand that you
know there's these brother topics like
say mindsets for example like mindsets
are very powerful things are you have to
understand you could operate a level of
a mindset and basically do nothing else
like once you change the mindset in a
right way you can actually get people
moving so first I might convince you
that I hit that desk is really good for
your health and there is data there that
shows that if you move it every 30
minutes or not not if you just once now
you have to move it every 30 minutes so
the annoyance at the beginning basically
becomes a way of building resilience and
building a mindset of like an active
person and you eventually adopt the desk
as a normal thing that basically is
helping you versus if I don't
necessarily use the mindset component so
I think the I'm actually discussing this
with Ali Akram she's a researcher in
psychology who studies mindset we're
trying to use this desk problem I said
like alia what's the issue like you know
they don't really mind that much
behaviorally but when you ask them like
they
get upset about this desk because they
take control out of you and all these
other things like simple des that goes
up and down and people just yeah Pia Pia
so I think we should operate at a lower
level of behavior plus subjective is not
leave it out sorry I don't think chest
objective is sufficient and also
incorporate higher levels of
understanding side mindsets and other
things to try to find the best solutions
we have a long career in front of us all
these problems yeah yes there's a box of
actual last week which is box in
software engineering and this idea of
box being legs arms to help a code
review came up and hi Austin and as an I
bought would be able to connect you with
another human to help you do the review
it's an algorithm for color software
developers I was curious in your chat
watcher my coach at conventions where
people interested just been interested
in having they weren't shouldn't talking
to a human for some tasks but may be
different in the but connecting them
like to your friend right being able to
connect affiliate autism I think I think
that that combination of childhoods and
humans is really the most powerful one
and we're really trying to like
understand first the Chad was a little
bit more we haven't done these like
hybrid but our hope is that we can build
such a hybrid now we have an opportunity
we are gonna be working in rural India
with the satis which is this group of
health workers that provide support to
other people and they have already
phones and they covered things and and
what we're hoping to do is to basically
create let's say a tree edging layer of
chatbots chest triaging means like
simple stuff like quick take today and
then as soon as you have like some more
complex need that needs to connect to
some other saty or maybe to like a more
expert like these are the liaison as you
will said so create such an
infrastructure if you must and
understand what's the best way to
traverse the hierarchy of support where
we believe that childhood will stay in
the in the lower level of triaging the
entry-level
maybe there's other choppers in the
future with more and rapida actually
might be super experts too and maybe we
can like
and to the suicidal prevention chatbot
so it's not just between childhood and
human but also childhood childhood or
human to childhood perhaps even like you
know therapists as a matter of fact now
you remind me the last interview what we
did with a person she was a patient
actually and she said like you know I
don't want to chat with my therapist all
the time like once a month is more than
enough but I would like to have the
chatbots to help me like remind me of
some things and I would like that my
therapist tells me like talk to this
chat board so I think the when I said
ecosystem is a true ecosystem I think
Chad Watts are not a replacement of
humans nor are a automation - I think
they are their own species I'm borrowing
species in a broad term of biology but I
think they are their own linguistic
species so I think we could find in the
future very interesting stop sometimes I
need a child sometimes our human vice
versa yeah but that's a great
observation
[Applause]